¿Alguna vez se han preguntado cómo clasificamos
diferentes organismos en diferentes especies?
Bueno, antes de ver eso, repasemos la diferencia
entre reproducción asexual y reproducción sexual.
En la reproducción asexual un organismo como una
sola bacteria se dividirá en dos células hijas,
que serán genéticamente idénticas a la célula
original. En la reproducción sexual dos miembros
de la misma especie se reproducirán juntos para
formar descendientes genéticamente únicos. Ahora,
en general decimos que los organismos que se
reproducen asexualmente normalmente tienen
una baja diversidad genética, mientras que las
especies que se reproducen sexualmente tienen
una alta diversidad genética. Entonces, ¿qué
es una especie? Ésta puede ser una pregunta
muy difícil de responder. Para los organismos
de reproducción sexual podemos decir que dos
organismos, como este gato y este humano, son
miembros de especies diferentes, no pueden tener
descendencia juntos. Sin embargo, para organismos
que se reproducen asexualmente como bacterias,
protistas y arqueas -que es un poco más confuso-,
estas especies no se aparean con otros organismos,
así que tenemos dificultades para clasificarlos
en diferentes categorías, y llamamos a esto el
problema de las especies. Pero en este video vamos
a enfocarnos en los organismos que se reproducen
sexualmente. Y éstos están separados en diferentes
especies, por diferentes formas de lo que llamamos
aislamiento reproductivo. Y esto se refiere a la
idea de que hay muchas fuerzas que impiden que
dos organismos diferentes tengan descendencia
juntos. Podemos dividir estas fuerzas en dos
categorías separadas: formas precigóticas y formas
postcigóticas. El aislamiento precigótico se
refiere a todas las fuerzas diferentes que impiden
que dos organismos tengan descendencia juntos,
que ocurren antes de la formación de un cigoto.
Y recordemos que un cigoto es una célula única
que se compone del material genético de los dos
organismos que se han reproducido juntos. Las
formas de aislamiento postcigóticas las veremos
un poco más adelante. Entonces, el primer tipo de
aislamiento precigótico es el aislamiento temporal
o de hábitat. Y el aislamiento temporal se refiere
al hecho de que no todos los organismos se aparean
al mismo tiempo, algunos pueden aparearse por la
noche, mientras que otros se aparean durante
el día; algunos pueden aparearse en primavera,
mientras que otros se aparean en invierno. Si
dos organismos no encuentran compañeros al mismo
tiempo, entonces están temporalmente aislados. El
aislamiento de hábitat se refiere al lugar donde
los organismos se aparean. Algunos pueden preferir
aparearse en el bosque, mientras que otros
prefieren aparearse en las montañas. Y si dos
organismos no encuentran compañeros en el mismo
lugar, también están aislados. Si el tiempo y el
lugar no son un problema, la siguiente barrera
es el aislamiento conductual, que se refiere a la
selección de pareja y a cómo los organismos atraen
a una pareja. No todos los organismos atraerán a
una pareja de la misma manera. Quizás un animal,
como un pájaro, atraerá a una pareja cantando
una canción, mientras que este conejito puede
bailar un poco para atraer a una pareja.
Entonces tenemos aislamiento conductual. Y
ahora tenemos aislamiento mecánico, que se ocupa
de la incapacidad física de dos organismos para
aparearse, incluso si quisieran. Un gran ejemplo
de esto es un animal enorme, como un elefante,
que no puede aparearse con un pequeño ratón.
Si dos organismos se aparean con éxito aún
pueden encontrar aislamiento gamético, que es
cuando la fertilización entre los dos gametos
para formar un cigoto es imposible. Ahora, una
vez que se ha formado el cigoto, podemos seguir
adelante y observar formas postcigóticas de
aislamiento reproductivo. La primera forma es
la mortalidad del cigoto, y esto ocurre cuando
los dos gametos de los dos organismos pueden
fusionarse con éxito y formar un cigoto, ese
cigoto tendrá una alta tasa de mortalidad y no
podría convertirse en una descendencia madura.
A continuación tenemos la inviabilidad híbrida,
que ocurre cuando un cigoto puede crecer hasta
convertirse en una descendencia madura, pero esa
descendencia tendrá una alta tasa de mortalidad
y no podrá crecer hasta convertirse en un adulto
maduro. Finalmente tenemos la última forma de
aislamiento reproductivo que es la esterilidad
híbrida, y esto es cuando la descendencia puede
convertirse en un adulto maduro, pero ese adulto
maduro no puede aparearse y tener descendencia
propia. Si dos organismos que se reproducen
sexualmente no están aislados por ninguna de estas
barreras, entonces generalmente podemos decir que
son miembros de la misma especie. ¿Qué aprendimos?
Bueno, primero aprendimos sobre el problema de las
especies y cómo clasificar diferentes organismos
en diferentes especies puede ser bastante difícil.
Tenemos una definición bastante buena para
los organismos que se reproducen sexualmente,
pero no para los organismos que se reproducen
asexualmente. Y luego aprendimos sobre el
aislamiento reproductivo y cómo podemos decir
que dos organismos que se reproducen sexualmente
están aislados reproductivamente si no pueden
producir juntos descendencia fértil libremente.